I was born in Chengdu
and I also graduated from the university of Chengdu.
Then I started working and founded Tap4Fun in 2008 after my graduation.
Tap4Fun is a Chinese company based  in Chengdu, specialized in developing mobile games.
We have been focusing exclusively on developing mobile games,
So the exclusive development of mobile games is indispensable and critical,
and is also the founding philosophy of the business to survive sustainably.
The very beginning of the business was quite  funny                                                                                                           since a small office was unavailable at the time.
But it was good as we got along with each other inside and                                                                                                                 outside of the office, and the dedication of the team was also very strong.
我们是一家总部位于中国的公司，但是我们不为中国市场开发游戏
这一点让很多人感到惊奇
从2013年开始，我们看到Google Play增长迅猛
安卓系统的市场规模也大到无法忽视的境地
所以我们把一款游戏放到Google Play上进行尝试
The income of Google Play accounts for 55% of our total game income
while players of Google Play account up for 65% of all our players.
The reason for this is that users start to update immediately within one hour
when we issue updates or uploads of an App
Google have a good developer relationship
They will often contact us
and inquire whether we need help or not.
Then they’ll get themselves involved in our piperline and give us suggestions.
Besides that,  they pay great attention to each game while also offering great solutions
Beta testing at Google Play enables us to issue                                                                                                                     new versions by specifically targeting just a section of players
Therefore we not only achieve version  testing but also care about users’ experience
By avoiding a mass release which might still have problems.
谷歌希望来自全球的开发者都能够取得成功
所以谷歌做了很多事情鼓励开发者们看到这样的成功故事
另一个原因就是谷歌的全球影响力
所以Google Play一定是我们的重点平台
通过Google Play平台， 可以让来自全球的玩家获取我们的游戏，享受我们的游戏，这点对我们很重要
A VIP customer support system is supposed  to be available,                                                                                                and the players paying money for the game
will be served by special members
We also attentively solve problems met  by players through the Google review system
Through this, user ratings from players have increased from 3.6 - 4.2
Meanwhile, feedback and customer service emails                                                                                                                         sent by players will decline by 15% to 20% in the following days.
As far as I am concerned, a platform needs to be open,                                                                                                                         generous and powerful enough to support any company or team
Looking to produce quality games for the global market.
And Google Play is just that kind of platform